Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This piece of work is an amazing application
of deep neural networks, that performs semantic
scene completion from only one depth image.
This depth image is the colorful image that
you see here, where the colors denote how
far away different objects are from our camera.
We can create these images inexpensively with
commodity hardware, for instance, Microsoft's
Kinect has a depth sensor sensor that is suitable
for this task.
The scene completion part means that from
this highly incomplete depth information,
the algorithm reconstructs the geometry for
the entirety of the room.
Even parts, that are completely missing from
our images or things that are occluded!
The output is what computer graphics researchers
like to call a volumetric representation or
a voxel array, which is essentially a large
collection of tiny Lego pieces that build
up the scene.
But this is not all because the semantic part
means that the algorithm actually understands
what we're looking at, and thus, is able to
classify different parts of the scene.
These classes include walls, windows, floors,
sofas, and other furniture.
Previous works were able to do scene completion
and geometry classification, but the coolest
part of this algorithm is that it not only
does these steps way better, but it does them
both at the very same time.
This work uses a 3D convolutional neural network
to accomplish this task.
The 3D part is required for this learning algorithm to be able to operate on this kind of volumetric data.
As you can see, the results are excellent, and are remarkably close to the ground truth data.
If you remember, not so long ago, I flipped
out when I've seen the first neural network-based
techniques that understood 3D geometry from
2D images.
That technique used a much more complicated
architecture, a generative adversarial network,
which also didn't do scene completion and
on top of that, the resolution of the output
was way lower, which intuitively means that
Lego pieces were much larger.
This is insanity.
The rate of progress in machine learning research
is just stunning, probably even for you seasoned
Fellow Scholars who watch Two Minute Papers
and have high expectations.
We've had plenty of previous episodes about
the inner workings of different kinds of neural
networks.
I've put some links to them in the video description,
make sure to have a look if you wish to brush
up on your machine learning kung fu a bit.
The authors also published a new dataset to
solve these kind of problems in future research
works, and, it is also super useful because
the output of their technique can be compared
to ground truth data.
When new solutions pop up in the future, this
dataset can be used as a yardstick to compare
results with.
The source code for this project is also available.
Tinkerers rejoice!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!